aucune raison de ne pas croire cette
explication selon moscou et ce alors que
le conseil de sécurité de l'onu se
réunit tout à l'heure à huit clos la
correspondance en russie signé verhaeghe
hoffman
elle verra comment la russie at-elle
réagi à ces déclarations de alexandre
loukachenko bonjour grégory elle le
kremlin a déclaré n'avoir pas de réseau
de ne pas croire les dirigeants
biélorusses concernant le déroutage dans
l'avion de ligne vers minsk où se
trouvait l'opposant biélorusse romane
protasiewicz pour le porte-parole du
président russe dmitri peskov les pays
européens n'ont pas la volonté de régler
la situation autour de l'incident
je vous propose d'écouter écouter tout
cela doit faire l'objet
disons une tentative d' analyse et
comprendre ce qu'ils aient eu lieu
nous avons vu les déclarations du chef
d'état le président biélorusse selon
lequel ce message serait en provenance
de suisse
par conséquent si ce n'est pas le cas
probablement quelqu'un l'ait démentira
n'avons vu aucun démenti à l'heure
actuelle nous n'avons même pas dans une
déclaration des pays européens faisant
part de leur volonté de résoudre cette
question pour autant que nous sachions
la biélorussie n'a pas forcé l'avion à
atterrir
elle était guidé par des règles
appropriées en cas de signal de menaces
nous ne voyons aucune raison de ne pas
faire confiance à la biélorussie le
président biélorusse alexandre
loukachenko a dénoncé des attaques
franchissant des lignes rouges en
réponse aux réactions internationales
suscitées par le décryptage de l'avion
reiner vers minsk
la biélorussie a fait ce que font les
états souverains at il déclaré affirmant
avoir agi légalement alors qu'un avion
de civils a été dérouté sur miesque le
23 mai après une alerte à la bombe
rejetant l'accusation d'avoir détourné
le vol pour arrêter le posant romane
protasiewicz merci verhaeghe hoffman
pour toutes ces précisions direct donc 2
moscou